you have a special guest as Kitty
rackleff is with Maurice Ashley well
Kitty is the president/ceo boss lady
head lady in charge get it all done here
in st. Louis up explore st. Louis that
is making sure that all the visitors and
tourists know about the great things
that are happening this great city kitty
how many times you been on the show at
least at least 10 you know they've given
me this piece of paper right here and
I'm looking at it yeah no kidding we're
friends we bumped each other the street
all the time and kitty what is explore
st. Louis let us let our fans and
viewers know why what it is that you do
well we're the marketing organization
for the st. Louis region for tourism so
it's our job to be able to tell the
great story about all the wonderful
things that are happening in this
community and why that is of interest to
somebody who might looking be looking
for a place to visit now I know baseball
season has started so the cards are in
force
we got the art museum of course in the
park all the great stuff that you have
there but what else is going on as we
saw some wonderful images right there of
the city is this the same video you guys
use just some beautiful shots there what
else is going on oh there's always
something going on here and it's really
a tremendous community to visit we've
we've just had a large number of big
conventions this summer and so that's
that's been really fun to see everybody
coming in as you mentioned the Cardinals
they're in the race right now for the
division leads so that's everybody's
really excited about that but the most
exciting thing that happened earlier
today other than the matches that are
going on here was the announcement of a
new Major League Soccer team will be
coming to st. Louis that's awesome the
the the head of the MLS was here and
announced officially that st. Louis will
be the next team
and they will begin immediately building
a new stadium that must be exciting the
difference that's gonna make to the city
very exciting very exciting and as you
know soccers a worldwide sport it's
called football outside of the United
States but for this country that the
sports really been growing and watching
the MLS expansion going from city to
city we really think it's about time
they added st. Louis because st. Louis
has a great soccer history that's
fantastic great news breaking news right
here key news on the show you know I was
at a comedy club in the Galleria
I think the helium comedy club I didn't
know you guys had good comedy clubs as
well we do was so much fun to go there
we do there's one there's one out at
Westport Plaza as well that's and
Westport Plaza is a great place to visit
Westport Plaza has not only a comedy
club but they've got Westport social
which is a which is a big sports bar so
to speak I mean there's just there's
there's a lot of fun things going on out
there and that's out in West County
versus being in the central core where
the Chess Club is here the Chess Hall of
Fame it was really wonderful to see the
interaction the other night from the
rapid and blitz closing and the opening
of the Sinquefield cup with all of the
all of the grandmasters interacting with
one another and so that's you know all
of that activity going on here in the
Central West End is really exciting as
well now you are part of the sponsorship
team for these Sinquefield Cubs and the
u.s. championships why is it so
important in this chess that's happening
here in the Central West then you know
just to see what's happened here in st.
Louis and particularly in the Central
West End where both the both the club
and the Hall of Fame are located is that
it's really it's really an international
community in the Central West End and
it's very exciting to see the people
that are coming in not only the
grandmasters who have moved here and and
called st. Louis their home but as they
come in
for these these world-renowned matches
and and the people who are interested in
being a part of that and so that's fun
and to see as you know I live in this
neighborhood so I get to see it
firsthand as I walk around on the
streets it's really exciting but for
overall for the st. Louis area the the
notoriety that comes along with this and
the interest that it attracts to people
that - you know perhaps be interested in
visiting st. Louis is is really fun for
us at the same time now I'm curious
every time you come on this show I asked
you the question you're going there
again
have you learned to play chess yet it's
been I don't know how long you keep
threatening to learn if you're leading
everything you got all the paws and the
pieces in place already it means
actually I've done that every day thank
you everybody lining up to teach you
what is it gonna take are you gonna
teach me I'm ready I've been right okay
you know that'll be a very painful
experience for you I know I'm right
there I met that level but right at that
low you've got to get that chess set in
your office so all the guests that come
in realize you know that your boss lady
I would love that actually I would love
to have a chess set in my office and
have people be able to talk about but
but the question then is do you play
chess and then I'd have to say no no I
can't we can we can we can get you some
we have something and you actually have
some really cool chess pieces and chess
sets across the street don't talk about
if you're not gonna do that
that's very cool just even look at them
even when I don't know like I saw one
that was Peter max I was very I thought
that was really fabulous well we have
friends and you're a friend and just to
have the website up explore st. Louis
dot-com Kitty Radcliffe a friend of the
club and the boss lady here running all
that is st. Louis all the great events
that happen in this wonderful city